I mean I read sex Adan awhile ago and
and it seemed relatively uncontroversial
to me but there seems to be a whole lot
of controversy behind some of the ideas
that you've put forth in that book why
exactly do people feel so is it is it
that people feel that their belief
structures are being challenged or or
why yeah I I can't really comment on
motivation right but I think there are
different sources of disagreement I
think and it's interesting because very
little of the disagreement is factual
it's sort of an overall all that books
[ __ ] there's a lot of cherry-picking
it's you know it's been debunked I read
that all the time it's been debunked who
the hell do but it and and how did it
get bunked in the first place
but I I think largely people disagree
with the general notion that women are
sexual beings I think that's a big part
of it nobody seems to have a problem
with the argument that men are highly
sexual beings that are attracted to
variety and novelty and sexual partners
I think that's so obvious that right
it's kind of hard to even conceive of a
disagreement with that but where we
applied that to women as well and
actually said women may be even more
sexual beings than men men in some ways
you know with the multiple orgasms and
the fact that you know a woman could
conceivably have sex with five men in
one session whereas a guy you know guy
has sex he has an orgasm and it's like
what's on TV you know it's kind of
finished so I think that's what people
find offensive not everyone by the way a
lot of people thank God
find it liberating and and stimulating
I've received dozens of emails from
women saying that they had to stop and
masturbate every 10 pages when they were
reading I've never gotten a single email
from a dude saying that he's assumed
that's happening
I I mean I think what it's interesting
because I think that for women the
lifting of the shame and the feeling of
liberation like oh I'm not sick there's
nothing wrong with me all my life I've
been told that I'm not supposed to feel
sexual desire the way men do and it's
natural for men but it's shameful for me
so to read something that says no no
it's natural for you
we're Homo sapiens men and women we're
actually very similar right
women find that often very liberating
and and erotic and and interesting so so
in a way like you're giving them
permission to to be a sexual person to
be a second yeah given them permission
to be a human being the Homo sapiens
that's that's the argument of the book
and not not just women but just all
human beings in general that there's
sort of this puritanical veil that has
been placed over our culture where even
talking about the the topic of sex for
some reason like I feel vulnerable just
just in our culture it's a thing that
it's almost taboo just even you're
bringing up that word and you get
something to talk about in public yeah
it's not to say that we shouldn't have
private lives there are certainly things
that I won't talk about in public but
sex I certainly shouldn't be ashamed or
embarrassed to to talk about sex and in
a public forum especially in a way that
serves the greater good yeah especially
with something that isn't just like a
part of life but it's I mean it's
necessary for a life and it's it's funny
how this there's this act that we have
to have to keep the human race going but
yet we're so well a lot of us are very
embarrassed or it is taboo to kind of
talk about in public well don't you also
think that that that's one of the
reasons though is we've treated it as as
only an act that is to keep the human
race going and and I think what you're
exposing is the other side of this well
we can also have sex for pleasure you
know it doesn't just have to be
functional right right man
Ryan eyes bedroom game is about to
change
you